[Music]
it gives me great pleasure to see all of
you here my name is giant Mysore and the
group product manager responsible for
enterprise search products within the G
suite today is an exciting day for me
the product development the sales and
marketing teams that are behind this
product we are pleased to announce the
availability of Google Cloud Search with
third-party connectivity moving forward
without further ado let me just get
started with what this product is about
why they built it and the benefits we
hope to bring to the market to the same
product motivating this product is
actually somewhat simple but it's also
somewhat it tells us about the times we
live in I guess enterprise search at
this point is a market space that has
been you know occupied by so many
companies including Google with its
Google Search Appliance for you know
more than a decade right but still even
today when we talked to leading analysts
who study how people spend time at work
what we notice is people waste upwards
of 20% of their time still looking for
information there are many reasons for
it we won't go into that today but I
think most of us intrinsically get it
finding the content that they're looking
for continues to be a major challenge it
has been compounded by the types of data
by large amounts of log data that people
are trying to analyze things like that
but nevertheless the problem remains on
the other hand the importance of
information in the lives of every single
employee has become increasingly
important in fact we come from the
school of thought that splitting
employees into knowledge workers and
everybody else is fundamentally flawed
there is a knowledge worker strand in
every single employee that's sort of how
companies these days should be thinking
about the workforce anyway now in this
context our thought is pretty simple
what if we made finding information
easy ass a metaphor that a lot of us are
very familiar with just go to google
write the convenience the intuitiveness
the scale the speed of finding at Google
we felt should be made available to
every business and we spent a fair bit
of time working with our system
integrator partners and with a lot of
customers were kind enough to let us
come in and observe how people look for
information and that has informed the
design of the product so introducing
Google cloud search with third-party
connectivity with this version of Google
cloud search businesses can now bring in
content from any location on Prem on the
cloud or enterprise SAS applications
through a rich connect set of connectors
and an indexing API all securely into an
index let me just get one level deeper
this is a schematic that walks you
through the parts of the product if you
will it would be to be rather immature
of me to call this an architecture it's
just a schematic at this point going
left to right you have the different
types of data sources as I've been
calling out on Prem public data cloud
services and SAS applications we have
put in a lot of effort to provide a
scalable indexing API and the bootstrap
the ecosystem provided an SDK to make it
easy to write connectors to all of these
different data sources and a handful of
connectors to get it all started on the
other end and this is a crucial point
what we learned through our user studies
and our own market research and
observing how businesses employ search
is the moment you ask an enterprise
worker to leave the application that
defines their workday for a software
engineer it could be the IDE for a
customer support representative it could
be I don't know it could be Salesforce
or it could be ServiceNow or something
like that
the moment you tell them to leave that
surface you've actually created enough
of a distraction for them to not want to
do it so the key was to allow search to
happen in context hence we provided both
what we call a query API
and JavaScript that allows you to create
that Google ask search experience
exactly where you are we call that the
invertible search widget and realizing
the importance of security to
enterprises a lot of effort has gone
into the design of this product in
preserving the access control models of
every source throughout the pipeline
right so we have had very gratifying
stories told from some of our early
customers where and you know somebody
went and opened a document and closed it
and ranking changes right to us it's not
a surprise do you think that's how
Google search should work but we are
very glad that it makes people delighted
right the other part of this is that we
have also put in a lot of effort into
understanding the importance of people
search so we are creating dedicated
efforts to make it easy to find people
so one feature that we're working on
from day one is to give users of cloud
search immersive people search
experiences as well right I am NOT
stating the two words that I think I
should state in every conference these
days yes this whole system is based on
machine learning and artificial
intelligence okay so and because it's
search we realize that search is an
infrastructure application that's used
across business-critical applications
and lines of business we put in a lot of
thought and made sure that this runs on
the same infrastructure that powers web
search so concerns around availability
reliability things like that should be a
non-issue right and along the same lines
we have studied the market very closely
and we have come to conclude that search
is a sufficiently sophisticated
application that deploying it should
require nothing more than thinking about
the number of documents you want to
index the number of queries you expect a
hit and make it easy for you even if
your estimates went wrong we don't want
you thinking about how many VMs to spin
up how many nodes to buy how many Linux
boxes to surround and things like that
that's really not what setting up a
search application should be about so a
lot of thought has gone into abstracting
the service to a model at which a buyer
can easily make a decision and use
without any without thinking about it
too much right so all of that is about
the prod
the part that I'm really excited about
is from day one we have made sure that
we think about this product as an
ecosystem lead offering what I mean by
that is we within Google are going to be
focused on what I would like to think of
as the difficult computer science
problems and exposing the solutions and
the ability to access those solutions in
the form of API is in SDKs
but the actual folks who are going to
bring this power to businesses all over
the world are going to be our valued
ecosystem partners both system
integrators and independent software
vendors right so the long list of
connectors creating custom solutions for
every business based on a deep analysis
of your business workflows is all going
to be done by our esteemed ecosystem
partners and I feel extremely fortunate
to say that even as we were building the
product we were lucky to get pretty much
the who's who in in the ecosystem when
it comes to such applications we have
sada onyx Accenture we have Perficient
twt we have businesses all around the
world partnering with us even before we
launch the product right we have also
had good we've been very lucky working
with ISP vendors as well and I'm very
proud to say that even today as we
announce the product we have the product
integrated with ylim ops which is an
enterprise facing portal provider
servicing several Fortune 1000 companies
and without further ado it will be my
pleasure and pride to say that the first
demo of cloudsearch that most of the
world will see will in fact be presented
by these partners they won't be done by
Google and to me that's an awesome
situation to be in right so before I
leave the stage and I start inviting my
partners to kind of come here on stage
and we'll have a panel discussion with
them I wanted to leave you all with one
question that's probably it's probably
there on all of your minds it is to do
with the availability of the product and
there's a deal right so the product will
be a
in two editions first if you are a
domain with enterprise licenses of G
suite and we are starting with
enterprise great customers because we do
want to have homogeneity in our user
base as we start rolling this product
out we are starting with customers at at
least 5000 enterprise licenses you will
get a pre-configured version of
cloudsearch with a pretty liberal
document and query quota you we invite
you to reach out to us or talk to your
account managers we'll be happy to
provide you more details and help you
get started with one of our system
integrator partners second and what we
are very excited about is cloud search
will also be available as a standalone
product so if you are a business that's
not yet ready to migrate to all of G
suite and what you're looking for is a
really good solution to to the
enterprise search problem we welcome you
to try Google cloud search we have set
up a customer onboarding forum so anyone
who is interested please go ahead and
sign up for the customer intake form
that I will be sharing next and spread
the word around if you know other
customers who are quite looking for a
good search product our sales team and
our system integrator partner team will
be in touch with you pretty promptly and
this is the URL that you should go to
its cloud.google.com slash products
slash slash search we welcome all of you
to sign up and we'll be in touch with
you to make sure that as many of you as
we can are accommodated in the first
wave of the launch in the rest of this
year with that I'm done talking here
it's my privilege to invite my esteemed
colleague from loom apps to come on
stage and walk you all through the first
demo of cloud search so welcome Ali CTO
[Applause]
hi everyone
so I'm Ellie I'm the CTO and co-founder
of flume apps and I'm very very excited
to be thank you to be here today to
present what we've been working on for
the past six months with with Google so
to begin with just a few word about two
maps for those who don't know us already
so as you may hear it's a French company
but with a global presence it's a social
and collaborative intranet it's trusted
by leading organizations like Colgate
Palmolive for instance finish line
Electronic Arts Logitech even Google
with Cloud Connect community portal and
much more so Lew Maps is an employer
with a unique positioning on the market
because in one place you have all your
internal communications to inform
employee engage them and spread the
culture you also have social
interactions between people in
communities and collaboration meaning
that all your business applications are
connected on on the platform the vision
that we have with the product is to be
the starting point of the cloud journey
for the employees so from one place they
can access communications so top-down
content highly personalized for
employees communities where they can
share ideas files plan events it's
highly integrated with G suite so you
have all integrations with Drive
calendar and much more and of course
other business applications the branding
of the platform is really flexible so
you can make it look like your company
and it's available on the web and on
mobile
on Android and iOS just a few word about
the vision we have for the photo search
so we share the vision with Google that
people want to find answers rather than
searching for cures and so we want to
provide an experience that assists the
employee and so that's why we focus on
understanding the natural language of
the user in order to interpret his
request we analyze the behaviors of the
users with machine learning to deliver a
personalized search experience and we
also assist employees by suggesting
stuff that they may not even know that
they are looking for so now I will do a
demo so the use case I'm going to
present today is about a picture
database so you know we all have lots of
cooperate and marketing pictures framed
for instance from events and wouldn't be
wouldn't it be great to be able to find
pictures based on their resolution
colors number of people or even emotions
let's see if we can do something with
this cloud search
so if we can switch to okay so this is
this is a portal that we published on on
Lu maps so you get all informations for
employees so big announcements corporate
content personalized information so it's
it's very personalized for the employee
and what we will be looking at today
during the demo is the search engine
that's been implemented with cloud
search so let's try to find something
fun so I will switch to the marketing
images data set that's been queried live
from cloud search and as you can see we
can find here results with a lot of
metadata this may delete data have been
retrieved using the cloud vision API I
will explain it after and so is there
something funnier okay dala you might
know this guy the one with the orange
glasses
the thing is knee is not really funny so
I don't know why he was picked up by GCS
but you know that's okay and as you can
see on the right side you have some
facets that have been provided by cloud
search and so we can refine the results
dynamically so let's say I want to print
something so I will pick up the
resolution I can see how many numbers of
results have been reached by cloud
search and if I want to say I want only
two people for instance on on the
picture and that's it you get another
picture
so I will explain just after how we
assemble all the pieces of the Google
products to do to do this demo so just
to finish the demo we also have a cross
data sources list of results so it's
based on the relevancy of the results
and then you have some custom data sets
that have been created here so party
once so for instance all the posts from
our communities are indexed and searched
in in GCS so here the facets are the one
that we define so for instance the list
of communities that we have and so you
can refine the results using those
facets and of course you have all the G
suite datasets out-of-the-box so email
calendar and an Drive okay so I will
switch back to the slide deck now
so are we made that made that possible
so we've uploaded thousands of pictures
on Google Cloud Storage and then we
piped them to the cloud vision API using
the cloud vision API we automatically
add information about the pictures and
then we uploaded them on our system so
we have you know categories colors
resolution entities in the pictures all
the metadata that you've seen during the
demo then we ingest all these
information in Google Cloud search using
a custom connector and the index API and
then finally we use the query API from
cloud search to expose the results in
our UI and you know it wasn't it was not
even out to implement I've been working
with Google technologies for the past
eight years and I really like these
moments when all the pieces come
together and we can present a use case
like this is very very exciting that's
all for today for me if you need more
information you can you can come by our
booth on the first floor you can miss it
and I really want to thank James and his
team in for that trust their openness
and the support that you gave us over
the last month and we were very proud to
be the first partner to demo this
exciting product and finally I just want
also to congratulate my engineering team
for the art world they put into this and
especially Evo who is here today and his
team so congratulations to all of you
you are the best thank you
thank you so much thank you very much
Ellie I want to emphasize one crucial
point there you can Lego brick pretty
much solutions across
GCP API sand cloud search to create a
lot of magical experiences like the ones
that was just demoed right now and
you'll see that pattern repeat over and
over again across lots of demos that you
will see now when the ones that we
publish in future so now it's my
pleasure to start the core of the panel
discussion and I would like to invite
the esteemed panelists on stage
starting with Chad Johnson from solder
systems Tommy from Colgate Andrew from
whirlpool and Bryan from onyx
[Applause]
well thank you all for taking the time
to be with us here today the focus of
today's panel discussion will be to walk
the audience through the experiences
that our Fortune 1000 scale customers
have had with Google cloud search and
the experience that developers and
system integrators have had with their
API is building solutions for them
because we believe this will be of
interest to a lot of you as you consider
cloud search and you kind of under
understand the power of the platform
itself with that let me get started
so first I would like to understand from
our partners here from the businesses
from Andrew and from Tommy why don't you
give the audience a sense for the
business problems that you're trying to
solve with cloud such I drew first yeah
sure so ours we had a couple of
different use cases that we wanted to
solve and frankly we we had a Google
Search Appliance that we installed back
around 2015 okay we used that for a
couple of different use cases one of
which was very engineering centric that
we called search Pro and it what it does
is it takes a look at all of the
engineering data that's in a bunch of
disparate different systems and fronts
it so that the end user has one place to
go to get all that information okay
the the second was actually our true
Enterprise Search which we had put on
top of our enterprise portal and so we
had a lot of things on there such as
things that were actually in the portal
itself but also we would bring
information in from Drive from people
search things like that so our use case
actually the the reason why we were so
excited about this was because we knew
that the the GSA was actually going to
end of life and when that happened we
had a lot of folks coming to us saying
well you need to replace it with this
product or this product and and we
actually had lots of great conversations
with giant and team saying we don't want
an on-prem Search Appliance whirlpool is
on a cloud first journey and gosh 80% of
our transactional informations in the
cloud now so it didn't make any sense
for us to go back to an on-prem solution
and so luckily we worked everything out
and in exciting exciting times
thank you so much Andrew Tommy do you
want to void some context of Colgate
yeah
SoCo gates on a journey to relaunch a
new intranet portal partnering with la
maps and in that journey we found
there's an opportunity to look at
Enterprise Search a true enterprise
source I think everyone here has a
vision for and and Google was uniquely
positioned to help us in two ways one
was being able to bring content sources
any type of content source in a very
fast manner we wanted to bring that to
life really quickly the second thing
that we thought was really important
that they were uniquely positioned for
was relevancy we wanted to make sure if
you're gonna expose all of these data
sources we need to make sure that the
search results were relevant so that's
why we made that choice thank you so
much
or do you had any thoughts on the API is
the platform itself as you build the
solutions for colgate-palmolive you know
giant I actually think it was all the
machine learning and AI three quick
things the first the quickness the api's
are so fast men the other product
manager was standing at our booth and
looking at my demo and he actually
blinked and asked me to redo something
because it happened too fast it's he saw
me change something's like wait go back
and do that again that that already
loaded it was you know indexing content
and being able to search for it in one
second with the GSA that was 10 or 15
minutes number two we write a lot of
connectors we have to integrate with a
lot of content sources google has made
this very easy for us they did not just
throw us into the ocean with an indexing
API they created a framework that makes
it easy for us to build connectors the
software development kit takes care of a
lot of the indexing methodology and I
don't have to do all the low-level
plumbing third the security
state-of-the-art
have not run across any systems that we
have not been able to emulate the
security model in cloud searches access
control model lots of sophistication
hierarchical inheritance
containerization for modeling things
like sites and folders I complex
identity mapping so I can describe
access permissions exactly as they are
in other identity providers like Active
Directory it's very impressive stuff
great thank you we feel very lucky to
hear that yeah over to you Brian your
experience working with onyx so I would
echo many of the things that Chad just
described and with a little context you
know around Andy in the situational
whirlpool like Andy had said this was a
GSA replacement and we also had a short
timeline because there's actually three
separate applications of Whirlpool that
are running on the GSA and we have to
get all three of them off they out off
the GSA so the first one which was
really an important proof point was
search Pro we had to get that built
tested and deployed to QA and our
timeline was about three months so the
goal was to have that into QA in the
March timeframe so we started in January
we need to get it into QA around the
March timeframe so obviously speed of
everything is really important and when
we did the original implementation with
the GSA it took us six weeks to in to
ingest and index all the content so
that's 12 million documents 21 different
content sources so we actually have 21
connectors that are running we're now
able to do that 12 million documents
when we can do that in a week which i
think is an extraordinary accomplishment
the API is our highly performant the
connectors are reliable they were easy
to work with and even more importantly
in terms of development the database
connector which is a reference connector
it was for us configuration it wasn't
development if we would have to develop
that that would have been an army of
developers trying to get this thing done
in three weeks it was a super reliable
connector we just had to get it set up
get one working prove it and then it was
just configuration for the remainder and
that was really a key thing that allowed
us to meet the timelines in the end the
attack
thank you so much Brian so that's
because the kind of the crux of the one
of the core parts of the value
proposition here is the ability to bring
in third-party data sources it'll be
great if you can one of you can also
provide some clarity on the actual data
sources that were used in in each of
your deployments all right I guess I'll
keep going so we've got for research bro
we've got four major content sources one
is a commercial application it's PTC
windchill so there is a connector that
was originally developed for the GSA
that was adapted to support cloud search
that was adapted by a third-party one of
the partners that you saw up on the
board fishbowl they developed that
connector using the SDK there's another
application which is the global
engineering system that is a massive
database it is you know twelve or
fourteen applications we're indexing 11
of those and they're each really running
as a separate application so that's
where the 11 connectors come from
windchill is eight different modules or
objects so that's another eight
connectors and then we have Google Sites
so each of the engineering groups has
their own Google site that they have set
up and maintained and then on top of
that we have the Whirlpool People
directory they were indexing as well all
told that gives us the 12 million
documents so those are the content
sources and and yet again because of the
performance because of the SDK and
because of the connectors we were able
to meet the goal great what about
Colgate yeah so I mean we have a lot of
different data sources the content
sources but we started with some
specific ones that we wanted to target
to prove this out and the key ones that
we started with was obviously GCE was
available out of the box so that was
that was great
but we also wanted to prove out that we
could do an essay peak contents or so we
targeted an essay P our MD system that
we were using and then we also wanted to
prove out a different data source so we
looked at internal IT support helpdesk
support content management system that
we have and we we use that as a starting
point as well great thank you so much
now over to the system integrator
partners as well in terms of your
experience of working with
with the Google team but in terms of the
feature set itself anything that you
want to specifically elaborate on
that'll be great for the community I
don't know if anyone in the room has
worked with Google before but you don't
ever get to talk to an engineer you
don't ever get to talk to a product
manager it's like the Wizard of Oz
behind the curtain this has been a
really amazing experience we've been
working with the team for about a year
and a half and they've been holding
monthly office hours with us they've
been letting us email them and ask
questions it's amazing some of the
engineers on the team like like Mark and
Howe and Tanmay these guys are not just
answering my questions but they're
talking through why we might want to do
something a certain way they're sending
us code samples the information flow
from the engineers has been what allowed
us to implement Colgate's solution so
quickly particularly since it was the
first one it was walking into a cave
that we had never been into before the
other thing that's been really
interesting is how receptive and
interest did they have been in hearing
about what we're doing with the product
what our clients want to do with the
product
it's very humble approach they are
genuinely interested in hearing what
they should do with the product next and
what the roadmap should include and
they're basing that they actually flew
out to our client site with us and
listened to Colgate yeah it's really
amazing thank you so much anything from
your own brain oh absolutely
and some of the same key points you know
the opportunity to meet the engineers
work with the engineers have open forums
monthly offices I actually see some of
the Wizards right over here and I see a
few more other Wizards are over there so
when we started the project at whirlpool
just to give you a sense there we'll use
the usual cast of characters you know
there's a few of us and a few of the
management SC types and then twelve of
the product management and engineering
team arrived on site so that's how we
started the whole project we had it was
a massive room it was quite a large
audience and in ever since then we
maintain those relationships in those
kind of contacts and for each problem we
had we had an opportunity to reach out
to somebody and actually have a
conversation and even more importantly
since this is all it was brand new to us
right and and it was our first
implementation and we had an opportunity
to engage one-on-one but also start to
have dialogue around best practices hey
we tried this we built this schema we
discovered this didn't quite work the
way we thought is there a best practice
well there wasn't a documented best
practice but there was a best practice
so we had a conversation product
management engineering on the phone to
talk about and learn what is the best
way to structure your data so when you
get it in the index it does the magic
that it's supposed to do those are the
kinds of opportunities you seldom get in
and it was like Chad was saying you know
it's a wizard behind the curtain well so
folks the wizards are all right here so
you'll have a chance to meet and talk to
them and ask some more questions later
I'm sure yeah thank you so much so I
guess the the crux of all of the
discussion is it'll be awesome to now
see a few demos so Tommy could you can
kind of walk the audience through what
is built at Colgate
should be ready okay so this is the the
site the search site that we built
souther and and the team built to search
Colgate contents what you see here is
actually a drop down for multiple
content sources I mentioned already or
recipe or Rd s ap content GC tree-sweet
content and our internet content is all
here so so let's take an example so I'm
sure after this trip is done I'm gonna
have to do an expense report so I'm
gonna go ahead and search for expense
reporting because I let's just fake that
I don't know how to do one and I see a
bunch of results here and if you if you
notice on the sources page what sudde
and the team were able to do is they
color-coded and made the UI rich so that
I can actually identify where the
content sources coming from so I can
easily distinguish the different content
sources and what they are so I could
contact the the expense reporting group
or I could go to a specific document and
learn how to do expense reporting so now
I'm done and I need to I need to grab
some of my receipts so I think we did a
bird trip yesterday's ago so let me go
ahead and find find out a little bit
about my uber trip I see a bunch of
different data sources like I said some
from Drive and here's a bunch of my uber
receipts but I'm not seeing the one I'm
looking for
I remember the drivers name was Melvin
he was a great conversationalist so let
me try boomerang
Melvin googling uber Melvin no results
I'm gonna call out Jason Russo from my
team Jason I think you had the receipt
do you mind sharing it with me pretty
quickly
yeah the uber trail
[Laughter]
okay let me search again look at that
well actually cook a tip from Chad's
demo on his booth so if you have anyway
to the setup booth they have some pretty
cool demo material around this search
but this surprised us we just noticed
this was happening this foot that
quickly yeah amazing the indexing speed
is super quick now I have my uber trip
that we took yesterday and it was just
around the block that we took that trip
that's it
thank you so much they say a picture is
equal to a thousand words a demo is
worth me not being here so thank you so
much for all of that actually in terms
of actual content I wanted to cover it
all a few we're more or less done if
there are any remarks that you want to
make there is some time to do that
otherwise we can open the floor for Q&A
there really is one more that I want to
add because giant as you know after the
application was built and tested we sat
down with some of the engineers and we
had some really interesting discussions
so I would say first of all everything
you heard about the core capabilities is
that's how extremely important I'm asked
what allowed us to get the project to
where it is but then what we sat down
with the engineers we had an opportunity
to sit side by side with them and I
would recommend this as the best
practice for all of you you know who
take on a project like this sit with
your users have them do search tasks
because you will learn some really
interesting things but don't tell them
how to do it ask them just to sit down
and find something and what we learned
in the process was and actually if that
when the Jif plays in a few minutes
you'll see this and so we would have a
user sit down and they say I need to
find a lab report right so the first
thing that they do is is they start
thinking about it as though they are
searching in their legacy system they
think about it as a database query and
so they start to structure their query
lab report and then you know blender
noise test for example a model shop
request blender noise whatever the the
search was and what we discovered in
that was their their framing a question
they don't really know how to use the
search bar they know how to use the
search ball we all know Google they
don't really know in the context of work
and that task how do you use Google and
so we said to them what if you could
just type in show me all lab requests
for blender noise test like yes that's
it that's exactly what we want to do and
so what we learned is they all want to
ask a question don't want to learn how
to search they don't want to learn
another structured UI advanced search
they just want to ask a question and so
the key there is
that's the next thing that we'll be
working on we are going to start
introducing that ability so that those
users can just ask questions but that
leads to another thing and that is you
really have to know your data you really
have to know your users you have to know
something about the questions they want
to ask and therefore make sure you have
all the metadata and the right bits and
pieces and the index so they will get
the answers to their questions I'd say
to chime in on that one of the things
one of the challenges that we had with
the old system not that not our GSA but
the pre GSA days is a lot of these
databases all grew up organically right
so you'd have a lab reports database and
you'd have another Oracle database here
and and then you'd have windchill and
all of those search experiences for the
end-user we're all different so you
couldn't just go in and search you had
to go oh wait a minute this one uses
keywords and this one uses you know
asterisks and and so folks actually had
to think about how to find the data and
not just go find the data we had we had
a really good story of somebody that
started at whirlpool and her job was to
design lab reports or lab tests sorry
for laundry and and she estimated it
took her about a year to get good at it
just to find all the information and
find all of the systems understand what
other folks had done in this space and
so from a from an employee experience in
the productivity standpoint just putting
this on top of all of that information
is just insanely powerful thank you so
much yeah and for some reason it took a
few seconds for the world full demo to
start after yeah it's a big file you
know giant one thing I wanted to add was
a lot of people have come up to me and
asked me why do I need this why do i why
do I want this and I start asking them
about their own environment at work and
how many different places content lives
they oh yeah I have I search Gmail it
works great like yeah but maybe it was
in Drive or wait was it in SharePoint I
can't remember and providing a single
search interface for all of the
repositories that has really been the
the the mantra of Enterprise Search
but it fails if we don't index
everything it fails if we have a room
with the lights off with with shadows
where we our search doesn't see into
that part of of the enterprise I run a
search and I don't get any results I
don't know if that's because I ran the
wrong search or it was because we aren't
indexing that part of the repository so
cloud search is one of the first tools
I've seen that has the scale and
capacity to index not just some of what
an enterprise has but all of what an
enterprise has and that's how we'll be
successful with Enterprise Search it's
great to know yeah one thing we have
done is to make sure that I like to use
terms like limitless while being humble
about it because it's truly limitless
how much lluvia not what about any
limits on how much you can index how
much you choose to index is up to you
the whole model has been set up such
that one does not have to think about
number of VMs to buy a number of nodes
to spin up and things like that it
should simply be hey I want to make that
new repository also available right the
connector and you're done it starts
coming in and that's also why we put in
a lot of effort into the complex actual
reflection effort so that again that's
that's an area that is so sophisticated
wherein we felt if we put the onus on
anything but the technology nobody would
actually do it so that's the those are
all deficits all gone in to enabling
that sort of an end stage for most
customers yeah um you know I echo Chad's
comments on you know just getting all
the content sources up you know we are
really excited that la Maps is taking
that partnership with you because you
know we're making that journey with them
but I think when we presented this in
front of our end-users one of the
comments that they made to Jason and the
team was that they were impressed by the
speed of the search and being able to
how fast they could get to their
information so to me I think what's
exciting is that we will provide a
front-end to the users that that has the
performance that they're looking for to
find insights I think that's going to be
the key thank you so much all of you
you
[Music]